un geste qu'on reverra souvent vu la
crise actuelle
désinfectez une salle où on a dû isoler
un patient qui ne vais pas dévoiler
qu'il avait des symptômes de lakovic 19
on a eu des passants qui ont menti fils
et à force de leur poser des questions
qui se sont en charge et puis on finit
par des incas reveniez soit dit aline
d'ailleurs qui revient du pakistan qu'il
ya tous pleins faits même quatre cas
d'omission dans cette clinique ce qui a
forcé à mettre des patients en
quarantaine plusieurs heures passées à
l'intérieur en attendant qu'on puisse
évaluer sa situation
une situation qui met en danger le
personnel et favorise la contagion
si vous voulez pas porter le masque vous
tous et si vous voulez pas vous laver
les mains ou si vous nous mentent et
puis vous dit pas justement voyage comme
certains patients nous on dit parce que
je porte un masque
vous comprenez que vous exposez les
professionnels pour faire face à la
crise on ouvre des salles d'isolement à
un autre étage on se commencer à se
préparer les commenter un peu plus cette
semaine les critères augmenté donc cette
semaine vraiment la deuxième salle est
installé les cliniques s'ajuste mais
plusieurs affirment toujours manqué de
matériel ont ici dans la clinique les
masques n95
on avait la chance d'en avoir du stock
du passé qu'on a accumulées dans le
passé
par contre on a accès à aucun nouveau
masque le gouvernement ne nous met pas à
la disposition de new york apparemment
se fait dire qu'il ya une pénurie la
communication avec québec serait
déficiente entre autres quand l
équipement de sécurité au moment où on
se parle on en sait pas qui va venir
nous payer pour installer des vitraux
d'organiser nos locaux et d'avoir les
masques criqui mort venir faire tout ça
plusieurs sources indiquent que le
ministère de la santé les cliniques
médicales tente de mieux coordonner
leurs gestes pour essayer de limiter la
propagation du coronavirus ici david
gentilles radio-canada bon gars